the only animal i think that has it
worse than humans is the giraffe i i
gave that a lot of thought i really
think it's the giraffe and then us on
the list of most vulnerable giraffe
we all know giraffes
like the child clown comedian hey
you guys like balloons
we know balloons they're round squeaky
okay
i just feel like the uh giraffe is like
god's first draft of an animal you know
what i mean it's just all weak spot it's
a giant weak spot on legs i think the
average lifespan of a giraffe is uh
until a lion sees one
i look that up here's my impression of a
lion seeing a giraffe for the first time
oh hey bruce
serengeti hey bruce oh yeah it's great
being the line i know i know
what an odd thing to say
i love being a lion i just think it's
difficult when you're when you're
attacking our prey to make sure you bite
the neck what the is that
one second bruce i
it's like i think like a giraffe to a
lion is like pornography
it's like a playboy centerfield they're
like that can't be real
traps with their spots oh are they
kidding you're not hiding
what am i roasting giraffe
finally someone in late night is
sticking it to the giraffe
the point is i wore a boot for a short
time we got a great show
you